MONEY FOR UNRELATED ISSUES.
NOW, AND 20,000 -- INSIDE HER
GATED MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
MANSION.
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS WITH US, AT
LEAST HE WOULD HAVE BROUGHT US
ICE CREAM IF HE HAD SUCH A
FREEZER.
SHE’S BEEN VICIOUS THE WHOLE
TIME.
SHE’S NOT AT WORK, SHE’S BLAMING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR EVERYTHING
AND SHE’S TELLING EVERYONE
FEBRUARY 24, COME TO CHINATOWN.
SHE WAS IMPEACHING TRUMP WHEN
TRUMP PUT THE TRAVEL BAN IN
EFFECT AND NOW SHE’S HOLDING THE
MONEY HOSTAGE AGAIN.
>> I THINK SHE’S BEEN INCREDIBLY
SMALL IN A TIME WHEN THE COUNTRY
NEEDS BIG LEADERSHIP.
SHE HELD THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT FROM DECEMBER 18TH
AND TRIED TO GET
MITCH McCONNELL AND NOW SHE IS
TRYING TO HOLD THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION LOAN
PROGRAM THAT’S WORKING HOSTAGE,
SHE’S BEEN A HOSTAGE TAKER
RATHER THAN A PROBLEM SOLVER.
THE ONE THING I WANT TO SAY
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP, A GUY
THAT I GOT TO KNOW IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS LISTENS AND LEADS.
DR. FAUCI AND DR. BURKS, AND
THAT PHASE OPENS UP THE COUNTRY.
HE LISTENS AND LEADS AND
UNDERMINES AND DESTROYS.
>> Sean: HAVE YOU BEEN
FOLLOWING BRET BAIER’S REPORTING
ABOUT HOW PATIENT ZERO IS A GUY
THAT GOT INFECTED FROM CORONA
FROM A BAT AND HE WORKED IN THAT
WUHAN LABORATORY.
I HAD SEEN ALL THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES THAT WERE MANUFACTURED
THERE.
APPARENTLY CHINA BANNED TRAVEL
IN AND OUT OF WUHAN PROVINCE
ACCORDING TO BRET, BUT THEY LET
PEOPLE FROM WUHAN TRAVEL
INTERNATIONALLY.
THAT WOULD MEAN TO ME THAT THEY
KNOWINGLY, CONSCIOUSLY, ASSUMING
ALL THIS IS TRUE AS REPORTED
THAT THEY PROTECTED THEMSELVES
AND SCREW THE REST OF US WITH
THE HELP OF THE W.H.O. THAT LIED
TO US.
>> ALL THE EVIDENCE INDICATES
THEY -- IRAN IS THE LARGER
STATE-SPONSORED TERRORISM AND
CHINA HAS THE LEAD JUST
STATE-SPONSORED PANDEMICS.
THIS IS THE THIRD OR FOURTH
PANDEMIC THAT CAME OUT OF CHINA
AND THE INFECTION MAY HAVE
HAPPENED IN THE LAB BUT THE
EVIDENCE SEEMS TO SUGGEST IT WAS
SPREAD AT THESE WET MARKETS.
WHAT DID WE DO TO IRAN WHO IS
THE BAD ACTOR?
AND SENATOR CRUZ HAS THE BILL TO
DO THAT.
>> Sean: THEY NEED TO PAY FOR
THIS BECAUSE THEY KNEW WUHAN WAS
SO DANGEROUS THAT THEY COULD NOT
TRAVEL IN OR OUT FROM CHINA.
IF THEY DIDN’T TELL THE REST OF
THE WORLD WHAT THEY WERE DOING
WITH WUHAN, BUT THEY LET WUHAN
PEOPLE TRAVEL EVERYWHERE ELSE,
THEY DIDN’T GIVE A FLYING RIP
ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE DOING TO
THE REST OF THE WORLD.
THEY KNEW IT WAS BAD AND THEY
LET IT HAPPEN.
>> IF IT WERE NOT FOR THE
IRRESPONSIBILITY OF THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT PARTY THERE WOULD BE
NO PANDEMIC IN THE WORLD AND
AMERICANS WOULD BE ALIVE TODAY
AND 22 MILLION PEOPLE WOULD BE
AT WORK.
CHINA IS RESPONSIBLE AND IT’S
TIME TO HOLD THEM RESPONSIBLE.
THEY NEED TO PAY UPFRONT.
>> Sean: YEAH.
MAYBE WE DON’T PAY BACK THE DEBT